let's take that same student who came to
you and said
zach i want to know how to write a
script that's going to sell
how would you talk to them about working
the craft of writing
how would you guide them i would i would
to speak to them about
the you know asking them again what is
it
what's the what's the idea what's the
what's the pitch
what's the what how are you going to
sell this to me because again
screenwriting is selling you're not only
you're you're not only representing the
product the product that you're writing
but you're representing yourself in a
lot of ways
especially when you get out there and
you start pitching or you go on meetings
um the
the craft i mean again i would suggest
that they do read
books like i mean go to red sid field
read blake snyder's
books um read william goldman's books
just try to get every
screenwriting book you can and then read
scripts
read 10 20 scripts
before you actually sit down to start
writing
just getting a sense of of how to go
about it and how again
read read you know 10
oscar-winning screenplays read tarantino
read them
alan ball read read
brian helgeland
robert towne francis ford coppola i
would say just read like all
great scripts uh herman mankowitz
i guess herman right who's uh the it was
who wrote a citizen kane
i know there were a few mankowitz i
think it was herman yeah that new uh
david fincher movies out with about him
but
um build
you know get those again it goes back to
reference get use those as your
reference
then i think i would say look you have
an idea what's your idea
and what's your log line
and what is that
what is it about that log line that's
fresh what is it about that log line
that's
you know captivating
what what's the twist what's the irony
and that's in that log line
and then from there just sort of
repeating what i said about earlier
about
then taking it the next steps you know
plotting exploring your character
wanting to know where they begin where
they end
um that's important you know what is
that where does your character start
is he loath is he loved by the end is he
loved or is he loads boiling it down
what's his journey what is he where
where's where are you taking us
what do you want to say with it what's
your theme most important that's a huge
part is
what are you trying to say with us with
your with your writing thematically
um you know is it about
you know the evils of um
of you know is it the evils of war um
maybe that's the best there are a lot
you know
um is it about a guy choosing between
love and money
um um you know uh
um how far will you go for a corporation
absolutely
absolutely what where where's you know
um
or you know again somebody a woman how
or would she go for her for her children
you know just watch the undoing on hbo
with nicole kidman
and um you know not to give anything
away but
that goes that definitely touches on
that theme and
um not uh not to the person that you
love not being really who they
you know um they claim to be or they are
you thought they were
unraveling them rambling the mystery
behind someone
so i think that is something when you
set out to write like what are you
trying to say
um i had a
a friend of a friend boiled it down to
this when you're writing a story what's
the story about
logogline what's it also about
what's it really about and
you know those are those are definitely
i think when you set out like
those are questions that if you answer
them and those are the ones that take
time but i think once you answer them
and you're
you're you're truthful about what it is
and you're and this is where you
where you see it going again it's like
answering these tough questions early on
opens up the story for you
and it's it's
but that's what i'm talking again about
working smarter not harder
you can answer you know again those
those 15 beats and
these additional questions early on it's
going to make your plotting process and
your
and your writing far easier and and
more uh more enjoyable
and you won't be banging your head
against the wall or worse
i like that so what's it about what's it
also about
what's it really what's it really about
wow yeah and that
is um yeah i remember hearing that
probably about
15 years ago and it definitely helped me
as a young writer i definitely like
opened it up like oh okay
it's um you know i i think it's what
it's basically saying is
you know once you have the log line
that's great
but what is it you're trying to say but
dude what are you really what are you
really trying to do with this
and i think that's something that you
that people should be asked and
sometimes
i think oftentimes people don't know
they don't they can't answer it it's
like all right well
that's okay but you better well know it
before you sit down and you you take on
the task of of writing a
you know a 90 100 110 page script
and devoting your emotion and your time
and taking away
you know time from other things you know
uh to really devote to this because it
is your baby it is your child
you want to know your child inside out
right
do the work do the do the uh
you know um do the smart work
i used to work at a company that had
that banner up above accounting
i know and it said work and i would
sometimes
transpo i would maybe that was my own
work
harder not smart oh no wait no that's
wrong you know and i like switch it
yeah yeah it is it's it's true it's um
and again i i for me it's something that
came with with
with age and and you know becoming uh
again maturity for sure and i think
initially we're
we're impatient and look i'm still
impatient but
with certain things i become less much
more patient in letting a process play
out
it's not always easy but in the end
you know it's it's it definitely lends
itself to more
um i think more success and more
productivity
if someone came to you and said i want
to learn how to write a script
that will sell yes what would you tell
them
um well i would tell them
uh you know ask them what their log line
is
and then i would really tell them to
focus on
you know where that where that where
they plan on taking that character
again i it's it's tough for me
you know everyone has their own tastes
and everyone you know
sees things in a different in their own
way you know i've
it's funny like i've put you know back
in the day i
i submitted scripts to contests and
they do wonderfully in one contest and
you know make it to the finals
or semi-finals and then i'd submit that
same script to another contest or to a
producer
and they'd be like you'd never hear from
them or it wouldn't go anywhere
it is it is just it is so dependent on
the taste of the person you're sending
it to um i don't think there's any
formula i would say what does help and
is helping
nowadays is
if writers have source material
um uh ip intellectual property
they have the rights to
a comic book in our newspaper article so
we were talking about
um a novella
you know a podcast podcasts are being
made
if you own the ip so many studios now
are and production companies etc are
basing so much of them as we talked
about basing so much of the material
on stuff you know on intellectual
property that's already been
written or or produced or you know
or spoken about in ter in the case of
audio in the case of um
podcasts so
that is one way to go if it because then
i think
you know if you've got a really
compelling story
and you know you own the rights to it um
that definitely can get a lot of
people's attention you can say well i
want to write the script
i don't know how most people i don't
know how again i guess it varies from
producer to studio head to what
but that is definitely a way to help
break in
um again if it's if it's a story if it's
something really compelling
or multiple people are after it and you
happen to own the rights
that's a nice negotiating uh bargaining
chip that you have
a new a good way to negotiate yourself
in as a writer
um so yeah there that's that's one way
to go
i i don't again um
there's no there's no sure fire way to
to
come up i think again if you have a
really great if you're just writing it
as a spec
if you've got a great log line and you
have an intriguing path
forward for your character and you send
it to a few people who are like yeah
you're really onto something here
then you know by all means see it
through
but as we know there are no guarantees
in the business unfortunately
or should the question to the person be
first off before you
want to write one that sells to ask why
you want to write
i mean it's not like you're selling time
shares and hey show me how to do it
right
now what's the hot market i mean right
and it goes back it goes back to
you know what you write you know
what you think you know are you know i
guess
you want to write right now uh the
western has come back and they let's
just say and it's
it's a it's a hot market i mean for a
while there it was after um gravity
right they were they were doing all
these
you know everyone wanted the studios and
producers uh of all varieties wanted
a great space film it's like okay so i'm
sure there were a lot of people who saw
gravity got inspired by our you know
becoming writers
and we're like yeah i'm going to write
that next great space film and it very
well may have been a great
space film but guess what the market's
moved on
and um it's like again i think
you have to just you can't write for the
market
um in a way you have to let the market
come to you
and that means writing a story that
it goes back to writing a story with
compelling characters
who you actually give a poop about
and want to see you know want them you
know and you have others who
are invested in them uh or in their
journey
it's um that's what i would say
and and you you ask a question like well
why why are you writing
what's the point are you in this to make
a buck or are you in this too
do you actually really enjoy the craft
and the process and all that
and you really have to i'm sure there's
some writers who have just set out to
write a script and they've done it and
they've made money and
but i think the majority of us we really
have to be inspired by
the type of story we want to invest six
months a year
you know if you're writing a novel two
three four five years into
sure so drive did well but if then
you're trying to copy
the style or yeah you you always have to
be
and i think you always kind of have to
be reinventing
you know yourself i don't say
reinventing yourself as a writer but
in a way yes because you you always have
to
come at it i think from a different
angle an original angle
you know look again coming back to the
space story you know
you know the market may move on but
maybe if you have a unique twist
on you know you know that space story
you know or
on a werewolf story or whatever i think
it's always having that
you know um always looking at
you know uh in a way
you could have um how do i say it
you can have a same approach to crafting
it but you have to have a fresh take on
constantly a fresh take on on different
stories and how you want to not
necessarily want to tell them but
you know you know fresh takes and
twists on uh on on you know
your material and and what you're trying
to say
and you know i reference 1917 it was
like not only was that technically
well done in my opinion i just thought
that
from a sheer filmmaking standpoint but
more importantly from a character
standpoint i mean we were in the
we've got to get we're with this guy
trying to get and it's really not a
complicated story
he's trying to get to you know
get across france to this guy to tell
him that
these men are going to die and it's life
or death
and his friend dies along the way and
man we are invested these two guys these
two young guys in the middle of this
brutal war
oh my god i similarly saving private
orion i mean
you know you don't have to be a lover of
war films to just be like
i was on the edge of my seat and it was
just and sam mendes is just such a
wonderful director but wow and again not
a
an overly complicated story but just you
know just being invested entirely in the
characters
and then you know getting there in the
end and
it's like he delivers he saves the men
and he has to then
then he's got to deliver this news to
the to the lieutenant whose brother
he was with who died oh man i mean i was
i had tears streaming down my eye you
know my my cheeks it was just it was
it was but it was it just you talk about
a film that just worked
all that stew just worked brilliantly i
like that that's good oh man it was
wonderful
a stew yeah that's good creative stew
yeah but i
but for me personally i hadn't
experienced that in for in a film in a
while and i
i guess i used to more but i i think it
shows where
sort of the where movie making has gone
studio filmmaking has gone to an extent